welcome to our lecture this afternoon
and a nice balmy washing the Z afternoon
welcome to summer in my book one of the
stories I found which I've always liked
to to relate which I won't relate any
length today is about a young man named
Levi Preston who had fought at the
Battle of Concord he's later interviewed
after the battle and to make a long
story short the historian wants to know
why Levi Preston was a young man with no
training an old weapon went to fight the
battle of Concord a good question if
you're wondering why one would go out
with less than hundred people to stand
up against the British military two
small bridge and Levi Preston went
through a series of questions with
historian and the historian didn't get
the answer he wanted it had nothing to
do with the team the tax on tea it had
nothing to the Stamp Act it had nothing
to do with the books he read other than
the Bible in the Psalms no Levi
Preston's final answer was very simple
you see he said we had always governed
ourselves and those redcoats didn't
think that we should self-government is
indeed I believe the theme of the
American Founding it's the culmination
of everything that the Constitution lays
out as a framework and the Declaration
makes as a matter of principle what that
self-government means and how that self
government plays a role in the specific
construction of democratic republic is
our topic for today at Hillsdale College
of course we are formed and established
to promote sound learning for civil and
religious liberty which is our
contribution to the battle for
self-government dr. forte is thinking
much more broadly about the intellectual
influences in making that argument I'm
very pleased that he's here today we
have someone else to formally introduce
him but I have worked with him for a
number of years going back to early 2000
early 2000s with a project that
ultimately came the Heritage guide to
the Constitution a absolutely insane
idea of creating a line-by-line book
that looked at every Clause of the
arkin Constitution and found authors and
experts to write about it from original
lyst point of view that book came out
2005 I'm happy to say all things
hopefully happening I'm looking here the
my friend from regnery publishing a new
addition to that book is coming out this
September so to introduce dr. forte as
is our tradition we always ask a student
we have no undergraduates here today
this being summer but we do have a
graduate student Hillsdale College just
a few years ago establish a graduate
school of statesmanship on hillsdale's
main campus and this summer we have a
few here who are doing research with us
and to introduce dr. forte as a railing
Braun who is in her first year the
master's degree program at the Vandal
school of statesmanship and hillsdale
college thank you dr. Spalding it's a
pleasure to be here today david forte is
professor of law at Cleveland State
University where he was the inaugural
holder of the Charles R Emmerich jr.
Kathy halter and Griswold endowed chair
he holds degrees from Harvard College
Manchester University England the
university of toronto and columbia
university dr forte was a bradley
scholar at the Heritage Foundation and a
visiting scholar at the liberty fund he
has been president of the Ohio
Association of scholars is currently on
the board of directors of the
Philadelphia society and is also an
adjunct scholar at the ashbrook
Institute of Ashland University during
the Reagan administration professor
forte served as chief counsel to the
United States delegation to the United
Nations and an alternate delegate to the
Security Council he has authored a
number of briefs before the united
states supreme court and has frequently
testified before the united states
congress and consulted with the
department of state he has also been
called to testify before the state
legislatures of multiple states as well
as the New York City Council and has
assisted drafting a number of pieces of
legislation he writes teaches and speaks
nationally on topics such as
constitutional law religious liberty
Islamic law the rights and families and
international
bears today he will be addressing us on
self government for the self-governed
the role of virtue in a democratic
republic please join me in welcoming dr.
david forte
thank you thank you very much I had
broken my CBS cheaters this morning so
someone left me these to see if they
would work or I could leave them as a
Benjamin Franklin example to my wisdom
let's try without for a while in May of
1797 a New York newspaper called the
Minerva published a translation of a
letter Thomas Jefferson had written a
year earlier to his friend in Paris
Philippe mazhai alluding to those in
government whom Jefferson regarded as
pro English monarchists Jefferson said
of George Washington quote I should give
you a fever if I should name the
apostates who have embraced these
heresies men who were Solomon's in the
council and Samson's in combat but whose
hair has been cut off by the [ __ ]
England this was not the only detraction
that Jefferson made of the fabled
Washington for a number of years even
while Jefferson served as Washington
Secretary of State he had provided
behind-the-scenes financing and even
copy the newspapers that had carried on
unceasing attacks on Washington's
character reluctant to believe it at
first Washington finally came around to
seeing Jefferson's hand and in 1796
wrote Jefferson directly bluntly quote
nor did I believe until lately that it
was in within the bounds of probability
hardly within those of possibility that
while I was using my utmost exertions to
establish a national character of our
own independent as far as our
obligations and justice work permit of
every nation on earth and wished by
steering a steady course to preserve
this country from the horrors of a
desolating war that I
should be accused of being the enemy of
one nation and subject to the influence
of another and to prove it that every
act of my administration would be
tortured and the grossest most insidious
misrepresentations of them made by
giving only one side of a subject and
that too and such exaggerated and
indecent terms as could scarcely be
applied to an arrow or a notorious
defaulter or even to a common pickpocket
a year later president John Adams wrote
of Jefferson who was then as vice
president and was his former friend
quote it is with much reluctance that I
am obliged to look upon him as a man
whose mind is warped by prejudice and so
blinded by ignorance as to be unfit for
the office that he holds Jefferson and
turn thought that the greatest enemy of
the Republic was Alexander Hamilton the
secretary of the Treasury who had bested
Jefferson at every turn while he debated
national policies in Washington's
cabinet while praising his intellect
Jefferson nonetheless opined that
Hamilton was quote so bewitched and
perverted by the British example as to
be under thorough conviction that
corruption was essential to the
government of a nation nonetheless when
it came down to the contest between
jefferson and Aaron Burr who had tied
for the presidential elector load in
1800 Hammond Hamilton declared to the
Federalist members of Congress quote mr.
Jefferson though too revolutionary in
his notion is yet a lover of Liberty and
will be desirous of something like
orderly government mr. burr loves
nothing but himself thinks of nothing
but his own aggrandizement and will be
content with nothing short of permanent
power in his own hands it gets better
watch this Hamilton had less kind words
for his fellow Federalist John Adams in
a 47-page public letter in 1800
asking electors not to vote for Adams
Hamilton said that Adams had allied
themselves with the calumny a tours of
George Washington while Adams in turn
believed Hamilton to be quote an
impertinent ignoramus these attacks were
not excesses of political competition or
petty Pike peak they reveal something of
great moment among the framers during
the tumultuous decade of the 1790s true
they had strongly held in principle
differences on policies on the economy
on the range of federal government's
control on the Navy on the judiciary
internal improvements and foreign policy
but these men who together had carried
the revolution to an unexpected and
glorious triumph showed a deep sense of
disappointment in one another something
even a betrayal for beyond policy
differences they each believed that the
other had lost that point of character
without which a republic and its
liberties could not survive public
virtue now we know in hindsight that
they were all wrong except maybe about
Aaron Burr but that was what they
thought was the point about the
legitimacy of one's ability to rule in
dr. spaulding's volume we still hold
these truths there are no less than 83
references by the framers to the
centrality and necessity of virtue to
preserve both Liberty and
self-government for example in his most
influential thoughts on government
written by John Adams in 1776 he wrote
quote upon this point all speculative
politicians will agree that the
happiness of society is the end of
government and that the happiness of man
as well as his dignity consists in
virtue George Washington I could quote
for the rest of the hour on his
in unceasingly tying virtue to the
enjoyment of liberty the most
influential term writer for the framers
was not log or Hume or black stone or
Newton it was Monta skier who in the
spirit of the laws defined public virtue
this way virtue in a republic is a most
simple thing it is a love of the
Republic it is a sensation and not a
consequence of acquired knowledge a
sensation that may be felt by the
meanest as well as by the highest person
in the state the opposite of public
virtue is corruption the using of public
offices for private gain either in
wealth or in power as bequeathed by the
wig writers of the 18th century wherever
there was corruption there was by
definition a lack of public virtue and
read the Declaration of Independence the
ultimate act of corruption is tyranny
and the King was unfit to be the leader
of a free people after the list of
corruptions that had been laid at his
feet by Thomas Jefferson but the mere
fact that montesquieu said it and the
framers believed it did not of itself
make public virtue so central to our
freedoms into our republic we were after
all not the French who sought to impose
the speculations of philosophers upon an
already formed society rather public
virtue in America came to be embraced as
core because it had become a value bread
of the American colonial historical
experience in a Burkean way it was
learned through the living of it four
elements merged to make what montesquieu
had observed about public virtue a
reality for the Americans for
the English conception of liberty second
the Protestant value of self-discipline
third the common laws notion of duty and
forth a nominal ously the adoption by
the American elite of a vice vain glory
first Liberty the English in their legal
tradition had a very specific definition
of Liberty it meant the right of a
corporation to set up its own rules of
governance and to perpetuate itself by
its own elected Board of Directors free
of the Kings will this was in a charter
for corporation where it was given the
Liberty to perpetuate itself liberties
were not the rights of individuals they
were the rights of a corporation or a
manner or an Abbott to make or enforce
laws within their respective
jurisdictions most of the American
colonial charters granted by the king
with legally corporate charters in most
of the original colonies the crown
guaranteed franchises privileges
immunities and liberties to free and
natural subjects as if they were and
every one of them born within the realm
of England a formal grant of Liberty
from the king was called a franchise
thus when the King allowed virtually
every colony the right quote and the
Herald quoting from I think the
Connecticut charter from time to time to
make ordain and establish all manner of
wholesome and reasonable laws statutes
ordinances directions and instructions
the King the king was legally granting a
franchise to the colonists to the
exercise of liberty of self-governance
the phrase to exercise the franchise
meaning to vote ultimately derives from
this older notion of liberty namely to
make laws to govern one's own
corporation or in the case of colonies
one's corporate political and
the twin grants of franchises and
liberties became central to the American
political experience and eventually
undid the Empire a central theme of the
opposition to Parliament prior to the
revolution was that the liberty of the
people the liberty and the franchise
meant the right not of individuals
against the state but rather the right
of corporate self-governance of the
respective colonies so for example let's
look at the demands and resolves of the
First Continental Congress the second
one was quote that our ancestors who
first settled these colonies were at the
time of their immigration from the
mother country entitled to all the
rights liberties and immunities of free
and natural-born subjects within the
realm of England another declared quote
that the foundation of English Liberty
an evolved free government is a right of
the people to participate in their
legislative council and so her liberty
was the right of corporate
self-government guaranteed by charter
that Parliament had no constitutional
right to take away it was a legal
argument that was the Liberty that James
Otis spoke of in his address against the
Stamp Act that was the Liberty the
colonists fought for it was corporate
and representational self-governance it
was not the modern right of individual
autonomy for the modern notion of
individual autonomy runs counter to the
second influence which led to public
virtue namely self-discipline the
government of one's self of one's
passions this second part of what came
to be public virtue was the moral
bequest of the dissenting Protestant
tradition which was virtually with the
exception of the Anglican Church the
common religious heritage of most
American colonists there is general
agreement among sociologists and
historians that Calvinism produced a
strong notion of
of control and self-discipline as a sign
a predetermined grace it was a hallmark
of the Puritans and the Quakers and
perhaps of the most influential sect of
the revolutionary period the
Presbyterians self-discipline in the
psychological is the psychological and
normative basis of individual liberty
which analogous to corporate Liberty
means the right to rule oneself
according to one's conscience Milton
said that narrow / Jenica Madison said
that in the remonstrance the
Presbyterian minister john witherspoon
president of the college of new jersey
princeton an educator of many of the
nation's founders including james
madison preached both of the providence
of god directing the struggle for
freedom against england but more often
of the necessity of self control of
one's passions he was no temporizing
minister but one who preached on sin as
well as liberty a signer of the
Declaration of Independence for
Witherspoon as well as for the other
framers self-government applied both to
government and to the self as John Adams
put it quote public virtue cannot exist
in a nation without private richer and
public virtue is the only foundation of
Republic's in this famous federalist 51
James Madison distilled the same concept
in these words in framing a government
which is to be administered by men over
men the great difficulty lies in this
you must first enable the government to
control the government and in the next
place oblige it to control itself yet
liberty as corporate self-government and
moral self-discipline as individual
self-government are not of themselves
sufficient to induce a shared notion of
public virtue
respect for one's fellow citizens and a
concern for the greater good of one
society after all increase and Cotton
Mather may have railed against personal
vice but Massachusetts Bay Colony still
hanged Quakers and sought out witches
something more was needed to turn the
experience of liberty of self-government
and the norm of self-discipline into a
moral imperative towards the common good
there are many documented reasons of how
that could have come about American
colonists experienced a multiplicity of
different immigrants and sex puritanism
theologies modified even succumbing in
some places to Unitarianism commerce in
exchange made one common with one's
neighbor without an aristocracy American
colonists experienced a commonality of
self-sufficiency increasing self
government institutions in the colonies
abetted to seek the need of common
ground with others and in the 18th
century the influence of the Scottish
enlightenment taught that the natural
ordering for the common good comes from
voluntary cooperation all that occurred
but as lived day-to-day by the people of
the several colonies I suggest that the
common law was the matrix that bound
disparate individuals and groups
together in a web of shared duties and
obligations the common law made little
or no distinction based on religion or
class or locality it was part of the
inheritance of the rights of Englishmen
so passionately treasured by the
Americans in their dispute with
Parliament in the 1760s reading the
records of the various colonies in the
18th century which I do one is struck
about how going to court was one of
their favorite activities we were the
most litigious we still are people say
we become so litigious
it's old that's all we've always been
litigious they with lawyers charles lee
and john marshall would sometimes be on
the opposite sides of case sometimes on
the same type of case they go have a
glass of Madeira together and everything
would be fine in another of the resolves
of the First Continental Congress it has
said this quote that the respective
colonies are entitled to the common law
of England and more especially to the
great and an estimable privilege of
being tried by the peers of the vicinity
in sum the rule of law transforms
Liberty as self governance and
self-discipline as self governance into
public virtue because it ties them
together in a web of mutually mutual
obligations to one another fulfill your
contracts do not let your cow trespass
on someone else all these were the
matrix of what people lived under the
common law and it didn't matter where
you Presbyterian or Baptist or Catholic
we see now how this notion of public
virtue excuse me we see we now see how
this notion of public virtue animated
the authors and defenders of the
Constitution we see it in the genius of
the separation of powers designed to
frustrate passions so that corruption is
frustrated and public virtue is enabled
but public virtue is not just an
attitude still less a feeling it has
been instantiated and conquer tized in a
document called the Constitution of the
United States listen now to the words of
the preamble we the people of the United
States we the people of the United
States in order to form a more perfect
union to establish justice
ensure domestic tranquility provide for
the common defense promote the general
welfare and secure the blessings of
liberty to ourselves and our posterity
do ordain and establish this
constitution for the United States of
America but something more animated the
leaders of the founding generation that
made the exercise of public virtue a
conscious standard of governing and that
was vainglory the desire to be
remembered for the great things one
accomplished in life notice that a
virtue few if any of the founders
mention is humility and almost none of
them reflected publicly on the afterlife
even in Calvinist terms rather what
every frame are possessed with the
desire for immortality in the minds of
those who came after to become as George
Washington did become first in war first
in peace first in the hearts of his
countrymen most of the founders
assiduously sought that kind of
immortality most particularly the
aforementioned George Washington he
spent his life controlling his baser
passions in particular his temper so
that he could act and be seen to act as
a leader on the battlefield where he
frequently wrote to the front of the
line amidst the flying musket balls to
encourage his soldiers in the revolution
where he refused any personal
compensation in his resignation from
command before civil authority at the
point where he had unquestioned power in
public life where he would not accept
public office until it could be shown
that he reluctantly accepted the call of
his country even after he had told
everybody he would in the constitutional
convention where he exercised quiet
leadership so not to be seen as a
partisan of anyone interest in his
letters of toleration to Catholics and
Jews in his presidency where he made
every decision on the basis of what he
believed was the greater good of the
whole and even in the preservation of
his public letters and papers which he
took the greatest care to make sure
would be available to later historians
Washington practiced the best of that
vice called being glory unfortunately he
practiced it too well he told Martha
burn our private correspondence and
being a dutiful wife and to the pain of
subsequent historians she followed his
directions so we have almost none of the
letters between Martha and wha m and
George even lesser lights had the same
ambition Jefferson was a master
behind-the-scenes politician but he took
special care to preserve what we now
call deniability so that he would not be
seen as grasping i think that the likely
source of the universal approbation of
the ambition for vainglory this is my
guess was the 18th century returned to
the classics every educated person of
the founding generation had been exposed
to the great works of antiquity
particularly of the romans who prized
vainglory above all cicero Plutarch's
lives cato Tacitus john adams for
example was a constant reader for asia's
particularly of the classics in the
original Latin at his death he
bequeathed his library of 3,500 books
men most of which had notations in the
margins to the Boston Public Library
18th century contemporary literature
also reflected the same classical values
the play Cato by joseph addison was
george washington's favorite play he
liked to watch it over and over again i
think even put it on it
at Valley Forge if i'm not mistaken in
one of the scenes of the play the body
of Cato's slain son Marcus is brought
before him and Kaito declares quote who
would not be that youth what pity is it
that we can die but wants to serve our
country we see now why the
disappointments of one another of the
great founders of Washington Jefferson
Adams and Hamilton cut so deeply they
each at one time or another lost faith
in each other briefly thought of their
antagonists as losing public virtue of
losing the rightfulness of exercising
authority in a republic and therefore
being prone to fall into tyranny yet the
Republic survived it prospered it did
not eat its young as so many other
revolutions have why not the Republicans
and the Federalists eat thought of the
other as beholden to a foreign power the
Republicans claimed that the Federalists
wanted to bring back a monarchy while
the Federalist feared a radical
revolution was being planned by the
Jeffersonians listen to this at the same
time as the founders fell out of favor
with one another the French Revolution
was eating its young in the early 1790s
during these same acerbic times among
the founders the french executed 40,000
people during a period when they had the
gall oh no pun intended no pun intended
where they have whether where they had
the gall to say that they lived in quote
a republic of virtue I actually formally
entitled that mr. ropes be recalled him
during that same time during that most
tumultuous decade in America nobody died
nobody died well Aaron Burr shot
Hamilton violetta was something else
later on but nobody died nobody died
because the frame is for all their
frictions actually practiced public
virtue they abided by the rule of law of
the Constitution they argued over the
command of the Constitution and what it
meant its meaning but not whether the
Constitution should be kept or not it
was the authority and the Constitution
instantiated the rules of public virtue
for all of his ambitions Jefferson
stayed within the constitutional limits
we had become indeed a self-governing
people because we a cell because we were
a self-governed the people most
particularly by those who held power
truly public virtue preserve the
Republic in its diarist moments but
without it it will not survive thank
sir would you share with us your
thoughts on where we stand today in our
country concerning the rule of law this
is part two of my talk I'm glad I
believe you rehearse that question with
me earlier because I've been thinking
about that professor Patrick Dineen of
Notre Dame has been pointing this out I
recommend his writings to you in case
you're not disturbed enough about the
way things were going Patrick Janine's
points out that think about what de
Tocqueville's warning was he said if
there is a democratic despotism it would
become more extensive and more mild it
would degrade men without tormenting him
the so I went to that section of de
Tocqueville and let me read you a
paragraph about the kind of democratic
despotism in other words a despotism
that can thrive without public virtue
that the talk Ville feared and so let me
quote I seek to trace the novel features
under which despotism may appear in the
world the first thing that strikes the
observation is an innumerable multitude
of men all equal and alike incessantly
endeavoring to procure the petty and
poultry pleasures with which they glut
their lives each of them living apart is
as a stranger to the fate of the rest
his children and his private friends
constitute him the whole of mankind as
for the rest of his fellow citizens he
is close to them but sees them not he
touches them but feels them not he
exists but in himself and for himself
alone and if his kindred Reese still
remained to him they may be said at any
rate to have lost his country above this
race stands an immense and tutelary
power
which takes upon itself alone to secure
their gratifications and to watch over
their fate that power is absolute minut
regular Provident and mild so what of us
today do we help self-government in the
Liberty sense are we in our personal
lives self-governed do our leaders
exercise public virtue yesterday I saw
an advertisement on television by
Verizon and I have to go to youtube in
order to get the copy as a cop this is
what it says maybe you'll be seeing it
so quote yeah this is a big quote right
okay nobody ever stomped their foot and
asked for less because what we all
really want is more that's the beginning
of their advertisement so that we will
want verizon there they're touching us
where we live if we look at the levels
of divorce children are born out of
wedlock the transformation of wedlock
the overt range of sexuality street
gangs drug usage the ubiquity of
abortion reality television virtual
reality video games it is hard to say
that we are still a people that govern
ourselves if we look at the range of
unilaterally imposed regulations by the
various unrepresentative agencies of the
federal government so that nearly every
decision we make in our lives has some
federal regulation attached to it it is
hard to say that we are self-governing
people if we look to governmental
leaders that respect not the limits of
their powers but that disdain the
mechanisms of the separation of powers
and used a simulation as a mechanism of
governments it is hard to say that our
leaders are practicing public virtue
that is why originalism is not merely a
a desirable method of constitutional
interpretation
originalism is a moral call it is a call
back to those underlying principles that
animated the Constitution those
principles that my friend Hadley arcus
writes about those principles that were
based and instantiated public virtue
originalism is a call back to that
matrix of mutual duties of individual
self-governance a provision for one's
family and friends and of the notion
that we govern ourselves through our
institutions and are not governed by the
institutions and that is why im a
champion of original ism not just
because of its text but because of its
moral freight and that was my prepared
second part that I didn't need to get to
because it was paid too long but you
asked me the right question math is a
thank you very so look it's the question
Shakespeare asked what prevention what
do you do and and i guess i would i
would add a one one proviso of my own
what do you do to inculcate public
virtue in such a way that i suspect
might be more successful if it were free
of the vice of vainglory how do we
educate the next generation those here
and those in our homes to have public
virtue and maybe be even more ambitious
at least somewhat free of that vain
glory there are so many institutions in
this country doing things right and I'm
in a group associated with a group of
institutions with with Matt and that
mostly on the intellectual level the
Madison program at Princeton and
hillsdale college the fund for American
Studies all over the country we are
doing things right we're educating
people and young people on the values of
what creates a truly civic civic
Republic the instinct of most Americans
is still in the right direction we give
away more money than anybody else we
give away a higher proportion of money
than anyone else we have higher faith
levels than anyone else but the emanate
the the the what's the word I'm thinking
of the the perception that is placed the
the examples of American life that are
placed through the mass media and
through and through entertainment it's
so contrary to the public virtue matrix
that there's there's a there's a true
there's a true bifurcation I think in
our in our moral culture that's that's
going on but because i think this this
traditional notion is still there often
fueled by immigrants I know immigrations
a hot-button issue but many immigrants
come with these kinds of family values
if you had a leader that exemplified it
and we look back and we all think of
Ronald Reagan of course but now we're
thinking in you know George HW Bush was
a man of public virtue he's beginning to
rise in our estimation as right he
didn't he didn't have the gravitas and
the historic and the historic
Churchillian moment that Ronald Reagan
did in his bones but he's the kind of
President George HW Bush that we could
not only live with but prosper it's just
even though we could disagree with some
of his policies that's the kind of
character I I do think we do need it you
know in a public representational way we
do need it from our political
leaders are elected political leaders
George Washington understood that the
people's values in and of themselves
could not be enough that the pup
Republic had to have examples of
leadership that incorporated these exact
values that he wanted the people to to
have and so I think even though we have
done all the intellectual spadework and
educational spade work around the
country heroes like Spaulding and and
and and Arne we still have to win the
political battle the political battle I
think will determine the outcome Herman
belts please
did I could uh I think what you said
about the founding peer we should go
back to that a little bit and talk a
little bit more about it rather than
talking about what's going on today in
Washington we do that morning noon and
night for this one half hour hour maybe
we should look at the founding and take
a little stop there so here's my
question what key policy issues provoked
mutual recrimination among these
political leaders and was there a moral
content moral substance to the charges
uh uh in the post gratification when the
government started and the Federalists
made themselves into a party in the
anti-federalists drifted into and with
Madison with them into a counterparty
but they were they what Willie I mean
were they arguing about the meaning of
liberty and did that have moral
resonance and especially economic
property rights and the use application
of property rights was there a moral
dimension to that sort of thing uh that
Herman Herman belts one of the great
historians from full University of
Maryland what the Jeffersonians in my
view what the Jeffersonian cently and
the Federalists differed on was simply a
practical issue the the objecting the
normative objective was the preservation
of liberty of self-governance and
Hamilton and Washington believed that
that Madison at least at federalist 10
and in his earlier incarnation believed
that the preservation of Liberty came
from a strong central government which
had limited but very energetic
powers in that limited area that that
that the country would collapse and
liberty be lost in the collapse if they
were not a strong economy that the
country would be overwhelmed and liberty
overwhelmed if we got into another war
which Washington knew was we barely won
the Revolutionary War he knew exactly
what what was like and how risky it was
and so therefore while the Jeffersonians
were fearful that the Federalists were
aping the British and and conquer tising
power in the central government and sort
of wig like they were afraid that the
central government then would become
tyrannical with this new power the
Federalists was saying that
Jeffersonians thought that the
Federalists saying no this is the only
way to preserve your liberties so it was
a practical issue over what would
preserve Liberty or what would not
preserve Liberty and they practically
went to the mattresses to use an
anachronistic phrase on on that issue
and they begin to stereotype each other
and and the press helped fulfill this
not fulfill but put forward the
stereotypes so I don't think there was a
moral distinction between the
Federalists and the anti-federalists
subject objections to one another I
think it was a practical almost human
debate as to what the most efficacious
method of preserving Liberty would be
David Justice to continue that though
from washing she did look at Jefferson
and and and Hamilton is kind of going
outside of the fields of the
Constitution that is he did what he does
worry about them calling it each other
monarchists and Jack opens the somehow
was going outside of this thing they
were trying so that was I mean something
sent that's that is a broader moral
question Oh in terms of the regime right
and does in and does not that the
success of that wash and kept them in
the cabinet to a point settled that he
wanted to to give their allegiance to
the Constitution rather than fighting
outside of the Constitution so to speak
that worked to some extent and that is a
question of public virtue is it not that
that affiliation to the Constitution
it's yes that's great studies of
Washington demonstrate that what
Washington most feared as an internal
acid to the Republic was the rise of
factional politics and that those who
held office such as Hamilton and
Jefferson should as chu factions and
factional rhetoric as much as possible
and focus as Washington did as in a kind
of disinterested public virtue in this
his prediction turned out to be wrong as
well as most as most political
scientists have been historians and
noted namely the parties came to power
anyway and so the the issue of parties
and the room and the Republic become a
separate strain of thought and a
structured strain ultimately the parties
became constitutionalize they became
integrated into the public virtue that
we civilized our policy debates within
the Constitution even through the 1830s
and 40s fundamentally we tried to keep
them within the constitutional matrix so
in that Washington was
understandably focused on avoiding the
acid of factions and didn't realize as
nobody would realize even Jefferson
didn't realize that parties could be
civilized or domesticated into the
constitutional scheme and still public
virtue be maintained thank you and who
do you feel are the leaders of public
virtue today that's a very good question
and I should have thought of that more
deeply should I not in your mind starts
going through the your your your phone
list of politicians now no no no it yeah
or I mean Everett we don't have Everett
Dirksen anymore right or even Walter
Mondale or Hubert Humphrey on the other
side we don't have those type of
characters anymore we've we become so
red and blue in our in our
differentiations we don't we don't have
people who rise above it we have people
who look for a jewel ation of the of the
masses and not admiration of the people
we don't have enough vainglory sorry but
we don't have enough in glory among that
they seek the admiration of the people
it's interesting if you named who's the
most admirable person among and here I'm
just speaking as a citizen not as an
astute observer I would think most
people would pick a non-politician they
pick Pope Francis or mrs. Obama is far
more popular than mr. Obama
and maybe for good reason you know in
and of herself not just because her her
husband has policies a lot of people
disagree with but you really non plus me
on that and that may be a symptom of a
serious situation that we have today
that people don't I mean there there are
people whom whom you think of that could
become like that baby Paul Ryan could
become a person like that and have that
type of gravitas and and since you have
some people who are thinking that way
but the media doesn't make much of these
people do they so you'll see them I'm
sorry I don't have a good answer and
that may be that may be the best answer
is that there isn't a good answer that's
why was waiting I I was listening to
what you said about there were places
mainly that you were discussing
universities like Hillsdale that were
putting forth the ideas and and training
or offering the teaching to the to the
younger generation but as a citizen I
perceive a significant matter of scale
that's that were behind the curve
because the education system was
basically transformed somewhere around
the 60 1960s and education teachers
unions and the whole purpose of
Education and the principles and the
things that were taught got shifted and
when you have almost a hundred percent
of the younger generation I don't know
if the words captured but certainly
incorporated into this type of
teaching if not a brainwashing or
whatever you want to call it in dr. 8
indoctrination into a set of values and
ideas other than the Constitution other
than the what made America what it
became and enabled it to be as great and
even as successful and even as
economically successful as it is today
and when you're teaching almost one
hundred percent of the younger
generation almost an opposite mindset
and set of values instead of behaviors
and objectives that would undo this as
opposed to continue it um how do you
deal with the comprehensiveness of this
new mindset and new direction including
with the media leading the charge there
are there are movements attempt from I
think the correct side of things
attempting to deal with that so for
example to to change the method and the
content of a primary and secondary
school education which is often just an
essay on on why America is so flawed in
its history you have to get at the
textbooks and you have to get at the
teachers the teachers there are programs
for example the ashbrook Center in
Ashland University run by Peter Schram
and now by Roger Beckett trains hundreds
and hundreds of teachers and seminars
during the summer on the principles of
the founding it's not enough yet but but
there are and Peter was in the National
Endowment for Humanities wasn't he in
that
in the reagan-bush administration SRAM
yeah and and where we've had appropriate
administration's the National Endowment
for the Humanities has done some some
beneficial work in that so it's not a
complete answer but the problem is seen
and there are some institutions that are
attempting to deal with it okay last
question perhaps uh Michelle Bachman Ted
Cruz and Mike Huckabee could be some
examples of some virtuous people but I
got a two-part question first what were
the early American views of Christianity
and how that impacts virtue and second
of all converts you be implanted on a
country without that religion or those
those cultural traits like Afghanistan
for instance what would you say to that
I know a lot about the first question
the second question is anybody's guess
now the first question is what was
because I've been reading and
researching a lot what was the the the
framers a view of Christianity in
particular it can be summed up in in in
two categories number one Christianity
was the best civilizing influence that
there was on non-christians such as
Indians that's why the federal
government constantly sent Protestant
and Catholic missionaries to convert the
Indians under federal tax money to
Christianity and and it was it was the
schoolhouse of virtue for the and this
came from the protestant dissenting
tradition education as well meant
christian education it was a schoolhouse
of virtue for the common people upon
which republic needed to stand they were
unanimous in that no matter what their
particular beliefs what the relationship
between government and christianity qua
christianity was was another story
government was not intended to advance
christianity we were not a caesar or
papist regime we had at the the most
significant religion clause in the main
cause
tution was there be no religious test we
would not be advancing Christianity but
we would use Christian missionaries we
the government the Republic to advance
Republican public virtue values not
sectarian values we would use sex Arians
to advance our values whether it be
missionaries or education so you look at
every single one even where you provide
chaplains to the armed services you need
you need the soldiers to be disciplined
to be taught virtue so it is a device to
provide for the soldiers for the sake of
the Republic there's this there's there
was no sense of Christianizing the
country or advancing Christianity but
using it as the matrix of our
civilization to advance Republican goals
the second part of the question was can
democracy occur in a place where there's
not Christianity and the answer is yes
it has in Japan so you have a good
example there or yes it has in Europe
another place where there's not
Christianity anymore but to do that you
need a different matrix of sociology you
need civic associations you need
relatively free enterprise you need an
open press you need a number of other
social mechanism sociological mechanisms
for democracy to take place so that and
this is then and then you I can go into
my Islamic but to give you just a if
even if there was nothing problematical
about Islamic theology in regard to
democracy it would still be very
difficult to have democracy in the Arab
world because they have none of the
social Civic Association allege
occasional rule of law free free
enterprise mechanisms by which democracy
can enough or free press they've little
bit more free press event democracy can
flourish so it's not just Christianity
that can that can guarantee democracy
thank you